i'll tell you a damn branch fell in my
yard that thing hit you know it hit down
in the yard and the man came
from richard's branch company or
something and he said eleven hundred
dollars
to get the branch out of the yard dude i
had a felony mold building
offered to kill someone that we both
knew that we didn't
you know i guess think should be alive
he offered to kill him for a thousand so
you telling me richards that i can get
a man a human removed from the earth
for a thousand but eleven hundred out
here on this dead wood
camera so i'll say you know what i did
i'll tell you exactly what i did i got
me a
fiskars saw i brought it i got me that
fiskars 18 inch right there
and as he's telling me as he's telling
me 11 i'm cutting that bastard off and
throwing chunks over the fence
there goes 200 worth right there now we
down to 900
richards